you must be a movie lover i'm guessing i
love i love movies i love going to the
movies
you know in when i lived in new york i
was very broke
and i i my husband was then my boyfriend
was is very tall and i'm obviously very
short
so we would go to the movies but i would
have him sneak me in for child's price
yeah now let's let's just so that you
were very broke at the time
very broken okay that's important to
remember uh but
how did you put you really you would
pose as a child yeah i'd be like
baseball hat
and like a big coat and we'd walk in and
he would order
order up the tickets right and one adult
one child
one child and then we'd walk away
holding hands he'd be like come on kids
this
yeah it would get weird if we would like
try and make out in the theater yeah
i'm not not the greatest that's horrible
not the greatest date night
yeah eating like crushed up graham
crackers out of a ziploc yeah yeah and
also there's probably certain movies
they wouldn't let you see
true yeah it was a lot of animated
movies a lot of it's a flawed plan
yeah exactly uh now did you only pull
that at movies or did you try that ever
at amusement parks because you can get
in much cheaper
if you go to amusement park but here's
the deal with amusement parks amusement
parks like i want to flaunt
how old i am because now i'm tall enough
to ride certain rides
oh so then it's just like a big show off
like look look at me i'm getting on all
the rides
which no one really when you're a grown
woman like everyone's like yeah get on
the ride yeah yeah yeah
what's your problem what's your problem
so when it took you a long time to reach
the height where you could get on those
rides
yes and still it's like i need the help
of heels
for some of them right what's your
favorite ride i'm just curious like
disneyland what's your favorite ride i
like a space mountain
i do i enjoy yeah
you know what's underrated mr toad's
wild ride
let me tell you why that's just my speed
that's what i like i like the way
it's just sort of it's taken its time i
like mr toad
it's not the wildest i liked it
it was probably they named it probably
in like 1952. this is a real
wild ride and then it's a it's
very nice yeah mr toad's relaxing yeah
it's like a magical journey it's like a
little it's like an office chair
slowly moving through but don't you end
up in hell
doesn't it end up doesn't he go to hell
at the end that's kind of dark in a way
we all end up
all right okay